oddio oddio rose dove siamo non lo so lo
so dove ha fondato come siamo rosso ma
questa non è la voce la roma questa voce
da pietro games vai alla voce da rosa
perché si è vestita di rosso
la donna da donna che ripete il ros
chiamata per tutto il tempo sono messe
per cento in più grazie grazie per primi
se vogliamo fare la casa subito no cioè
prefetto grande facciamola piatto allora
io faccio le fondamenta la facciamo qua
sopra e facciamo due entrati una da una
parte una dall'altra buoni raia potrebbe
andar peggio che oltre il periodo 9 mag
ma chi il cervello ce l'hai nella testa
che entro lei lasciato sul comodino come
se letti qua perché siccome so che tu
hai tendenze omosessuali o distaccato un
letto all'altro
no no no no no metti metti il pene nelle
mutande togli elettorali
vogliamo andare a vedere subito cosa c'e
nel corso dei 4 curioso bene vai miniera
a destra c'è del legno che possiamo
saccheggiare che passa peggio saccheggia
c'è un sacco di miniere legno il legno
al mio dio cosa ho visto aiuto che è
trovato al suo vivo sono io ho perso lo
smalto in questa è la questo l'inferno
porca vacca c'era la scardigno dell'isis
sottovia no sono sono un deficiente
posso cancellare il crafting fatto no ho
creato 44 bottoni
di questi d'occhio ti faccio fuori oh
mamma via the team va bene ma ora che ti
spacco la famiglia vi ammazzo di gallina
che sono qui dentro
guardate se tu ti stai accettando per
delle uova di gallina vai scopate di
pietro chiama questo were limone tra
polli esatto fichissimo cazzo grandi
mentre limone la madonna quando veloce
dobbiamo entrare tutti insieme quadraro
ma allora sei stronzo jolo strisce non
sono scemo se lo siamo affatto legata
bruttissimi lascio aiuto pieno aiuto
aiuto pietro aiuto dietro ai a romperlo
per loro si scelgono mettiamo torce
disattiviamo raccolgono milano a mio
figlio diamante zitto dai più diner già
tanto fa per avere ancora ritmo quanto
c'e niente da anni zitto diario 15 ma io
non so non sono mano dovrebbe non sono
studiato cos'è marina però marina marina
marina aiuto a questa roba
ti fanno male quelli di beccano così si
chiamano i guardiani dei che ha questa
spada vieni qua aspettai a guardava ci
sono delle cose scritte in inglese
metti tutto nella cesta che basta che
crescano le piante nell'aria 20 20 22
diamanti totale come mangiare come
allietare il nostro appetito
se non con le poesie di d'annunzio la
preghiera
la preghiera ok tirava il pesce di
napoli pesce ok nome nobel pesce l'altro
però a ok ecco perché quel pesce
grazie signore che lino spedizione ci
hai fatto trovare un sacco di diamanti
non glielo trovati vivo quindi grazie
famigliari non si mangia grazie signore
che siamo finiti sull'isola deserta
vabbè mangiamo ma tu sei stupido maggio
si stupido ma si butta no no no no fermo
ma sei pazzo t'ammazzo lava tempo io sta
che il cartello di volta candiano della
serie fatto e statista ci sono in avaria
ma cosa si saranno blazek management
sparagli chiamante sharpless 5 la gara è
un ragazzo che sono fuori ma iniziano a
siti fuori
e invece no melo zucchi primo tempio
romano maggiore mikasa tempi romano
cos'è sta roba qua viola si sono caduto
nell'acqua un miliardo di porte qualche
facciamo sembra ogni volta ci sono forti
nelle porte entra a capo a marco tutto
quanto mai fatti vedere in faccia
stai bene oggi era bella cera non è che
c'è qualcosa fuori nascosto ma morì dove
però qualcosa mi piacciono sherlock
holmes e diamo no che perché se invece
c'era una cesta la scossa sopra la
[ __ ] tre diamanti pure
del raggiro vediamo qua jungle tempo poi
cosa gesù sto vedendo cosa aiuto dietro
ai madonna che male madonna che schiaffi
sto prendendo aiuto ai adesso una volta
piacciono molto te lo giuro sono tutti
tutti quanti sono morti in questo
istante a meno che non mi muro vivo ma
non cosa per curarmi insomma morto sono
vi sono invece un tiro sul no non ci
posso credere
no si può credere non ci voglio credere
la porta è difficilissimo te lo giuro
sento come scendi di choc sono scillone
uscito prima con un cuore modo ancora
alloggi numero di salvo per accumulo poi
con l'esperienza c'è in giro si madonna
46 pieno di frecce vabbè dire che
possiamo uscire beh mi chiamo fatto che
sarà stavolta facciamo la casa
sott'acqua c'è una luce che proviene da
dentro
apri la porta pirla non si entra salve
non sò se è contento che siamo entrati
poverino lasciava ha fatto niente è
malaccio ma noi ci aveva fatto niente
magari voleva solo accoglierci a posto
da gioco fido andar via
even perfetto la partenza è buona ma c'è
un altro fi per occhio scusa sul clima
ok poi mio zio alla casa a superare la
mia completata ragazze hai tenuto la
difficoltà a massimo vero dirsi libero
che non stanno guardando breaking bad
avaya schiacciato quindi c'è un cretino
tempo difficoltà easy è facile ma non
riescono a vederlo quindi traffico
facile cosa apple eccolo vedo vedo
ti ricordi quel post non visto il tipo
il primo episodio non è vero non ci
credi bene e allora guarda il tempo la
posto appunto dragon's lair pd water
tempo next to one hanno subito così per
farmi mangiare che ho fame
ma torta di frutta cosa che aiuta
aiutami aiutami pietro che trojan che
balle agli usa la donna che dolore ma
diego non ci sono pagato ma lee joon
park era già aperto qua a noi è stato il
gripen vaime lamenta yemen ha detto
spacca gli acquisti sono cavata male che
siamo stati bravi anche stavolta cioè
alla fine ce la siamo cavata bene
questo è il rituale per battere il drago
del land dopo va bene no ecco lo uccide
il pulcino e batteremo il drago ma io
proprio con questo elemento dovevo fare
una serie di minecraft direi che così
come siamo messi può della roba in più
che ho per andare a mangiare andiamo
alle solite dragonslayer by prima tu fai
prima di segnare vado prima voce a max
occhi niente prese il nome 12 punti
reali ma io 12 il culo
ne ho precisi né punturo nella sala hai
una freccia hai sempre celermente la più
una non è portare va persa grazie
puoi essere più stupida puoi essere una
persona perché ighalo l'ho presa neanche
i video e faccio le ultime questo
mandato letta scolpito vediamo se altri
raggi drago ha già perso vita al drago
ma era il pci traggono bene tu brutto
inutile essere umano crasha proprio
quando serve a masate pietro vi prego
ammazzato iblea le intermediazioni
spero che ti ammazzo a frau pietro mai
mancato
che figata io ho preparato un pensierino
un ricordo un regalo ad arte per
celebrare questa ultima puntata di
naufraghi insieme chissà perché non mi
aspetto niente di buono
vai lì mi dedico questo è un regalo
fatto col cuore
vai ma non i portolani ma che palle ma
basta
dovrei mettere le teste di guida dove ho
messo le torce ok non ne vai vai come
aiuto vero gigante aiuto cose grosso la
nostra casa come l'arezzo aiuto madonna
che male che male che male a chiamare fa
benissimo
madonna e furti conosco forte aiuto è
morto ma la nostra isola pietro varie
decisione se mai lo presti contesto lo
pesca l'hack è male female to search
sopravolta l'hai ucciso hyatt sto
morendo pietro continua senz'anima
ma chi ha trovato qualcosa almeno la
stella con questa cosa che possiamo fare
di me un p con quello che si mangia nel
panino da pure il bacon e cosa è un
falso fare il far bene così ci trovano
evento storico a salvarci barsa fi non
facciamo fare fare fare motta koch ha
visto ma che figata incredibile che figo
sono portale ma qualcuno lo vede suo
segnale maledetto dieci giorni possiamo
fare niente
la smetti di fischiettare possono io e
tu chi col chi diavolo saresti spiegami
ragazzi ho visto segnale se miracolato
da pesca ti do una barca va bene ma lei
ha una barca per sé qualcosa del giorno
realtà misto schiantato quindi non ce
l'ho più però vi raggiungo vi raggiungo
ai partiti ragazzi tranquilli enti a cui
aggiungo va bene andiamo
dobbiamo andare dritti dritti dritti
va bene quando qualcosa vedo qualcosa e
questo e questo mi aiuta pollo aiutami
tu hai capito niente una gallina mia
scassa tutta la barca però vabbè da che
parte andiamo uomo e non solo di
mescolare voglio andare dove viva e non
fermarmi qua questo viaggio mi porterà
da tutti può che girovagando col mio
pietro io vi lascio tutti indietro c'è
una roba dico di ragnatele ci sono i
ragni pietro che schifo no magari no no
tsuki c'è aiuto e aiuto si era
esattamente quello che speravo una spada
fortissima ha fortunatamente abbia
tratto st spada che un pochino proteggi
minore protegge e tu sai una freccia nel
cervello forse più intelligente di prima
grazie
c'è un'altra festa amico mi ami ami
controllare vuota mi conceda o gli
stivali di fa la da subito i tuoi occhi
da falco stanno portando gli hobbit
isengard dove la facciamo questa casa
quindi isengard perfetto dove isengard
dove stanno per tutti i capi serve cubo
torri e sulla torre
secondo me guarda che sto dungeon qua
avrà sotto nella montagna dentro
incavato un'apertura gigante un'arena un
qualcosa poi scopre che in realtà non
c'è niente c'è uno sgabuzzino stupido
prima le donne ma perché non ti ammazzi
nel fuoco perché non accennino quando
serve aiuto aiuto
aspetta aspetta che ci ho visto cose ci
sono le espone
ammazzatelo ammazzato si vi amo siamo sì
grazie
definiti non credo ce n c'è una cesta in
una gabbia cena ci sia una gabbia occhio
stiamo malissimo parco e ti spacchi work
[Musica]
mi sembra il signore degli anelli quando
attraverso il passo del [ __ ] non
vi ricordo che si chiama il passo al
passo di il posto del [ __ ] a
caravaggesca la scala scarafaggi skalka
scarafaggi skanska guarda c'è una pecora
nera lì e poi c'è anche questo animale
grazioso cos'è questa roba qua aspetta
aspetta
ciao amici ciao 16 11 11 anni mi spingo
yo yo va il secondo aia anch'io
beh è stato è stato veramente bello tipo
gardaland c'è un ragno velenoso occhio
ucciso ma due hanno avuto sono forte
questa spada incredibile meno male
perché costa difficoltà quando faremo un
passo
chi giura non l'avevo visto sto
precipito ci avevo installava destra non
pensavo ceneri nel diamante le dia ma
qui c'è una cesta 3 2 1 aprile mentre
tutti i picchi non c'era niente che
sfiga
andiamo cosa stai facendo cosa era
comoda è il giorno grazie a dio meno
male che azzecchiamo sempre riuscite
giuste ai da mangiare t
ma no non te lo do allora ce l'ho io non
m'annoio 2000 strato di pan quanti ne
hai quanti ai io mi avvicino riprende il
maggio grazie ad esso fai la stessa cosa
quelle banconote da 50 a ma fosse una
specie di collina fatta sabbia come
quanto figo piramide siano arrivo di
trappole quindi tanto mi sono murato
dentro sono scemo io va bene vai
spaccatutto spacca tutto lascia
hanno sparato no no no no
mamma mia quanto stanno sfornando
buonissimo che ce l'abbiamo fatto fammi
capire un attimo 9 ma che casino è un
labirinto loreo dio mi sembra giocare
renderman un'ora che stiamo andando
avanti giusta piramide e aspetto che
consistono casi mi sa che siamo arrivati
ad una delle stanze porca vacca cosa
vedo lancia una piena e di pietro nonna
che casino
basta c'è ancora una schiatta porca
vacca cosa c'era dentro
niente no no grazie pietro finiamo via
prendi la barca maledizioni stavano
splendono chi per forza andiamo via
ma che c'è il tramonto e nessuno ci
rompe le balle figlia faceva giungla 4
la madre ma quanto figo questo prima le
signore no no no no no no no no no no è
troppo
no è la sfida è una spina nella da chi
entra nel pozzo si no
la goduria anche voi non puoi cadere
perché ci succederà vai con le torce
matrona che brutto questo ti sei visto
allo specchio
allora va bene vacca spacca nona ferri
con due cuori che spacca io ne ho due e
mezzo questo come o mio dio
vuoi vedere che cosa che cosa è dovuto
questo casino dami l'arco brut coaching
stai a vedere allora facciamo così to
hide armature la spada alle domande all
arco mike sarei la mia katniss everdeen
one
iterativi later abbiamo guarda c'è ci
sono delle erbette pietro abbiamo un
problema
cosa che mi seguono un po di cani ha
detto cani che mi si è diventato un
canile guarda loro continuo diventato
nintendogs abbiamo quest'anno era danno
anche aveva già fatto no no era voler
anni quello che faceva vulcano qua ma è
un dungeon e book giudici credo o mio
dio in una scusa scusa scusa mi dispiace
volevo togliere l'altra torce altro
giuro che non l'ho fatta
volevo fare non l'ho fatto apposta per
oggi a posto porca vacca allora forza
vacca il pool sette e otto quadri adami
con l'inferno almeno io ho lago di
lismore del gods reboot godley leggins
cornice smette gol lealmente pensa un po
attrici comunque morire come riesco
anche a morire esatto siamo pietro
stiamo per uscire 6 no ma sono zombie
quasi tutta stavo per vedere la scena
primo bella della vita stava per morire
l'accesso a internet io che sono fatta
in un po i sogni in ferro non posso che
i danni secondo rio che come sono
scusami così che tendiamo a non me lo
ricordavo entriamo sì c'è il portale
cioè portare vai entra siamo arrivati
all and now mi sono pagato ma spendono
pietro non ho archi non ho niente avermi
menano mi vedono
non l'ho guardato in ammirato a caso mi
aveva attaccato menaye donkor da porca
put nuovo ci sono morto morto io sono
caduto e ho perso tutto quanto verso ho
capito
gesù in terra non è vero sto prendo io
non è vero nella vita sei pronto allora
pronto
sì ma ci 6 3 2 1 dai guardalinee
guardate guardate no core di studio
presso fortezza
bye bye bye ok ok che potrebbe esserci
qualcuno dentro qualche disagio
intanto chi ha tempo per morire non lo
sta uccidendo la radio picchio linea
vanno lì niente sono solo o poi dei
pescaresi e può anche discutere sono qui
come nomi di un cappello occhio che
rendermi indietro e manda non mi beccano
colpisce colpisce pubblici ufficiali a
chi è male forte ragazze va bè cosa vedo
lì occhio e sali salita io non l'ho
occupato il tempo occupato salis
ma dopo anche la torre vicine per un in
scadenza di questa volta buona mai
perfetto va bene senti tu no d'acciaio
android stones e voglio che tattica
adwords è lo so che ai turisti.mai
mancino ciao sono fatta ragazzi guardate
mi voglio mandare gli under man city
incazzati che peccato
senior iii e anche quest'isola è stata
completata ci abbiamo messo un sacco è
stato molto difficile vendotutto dosare
le ultime frecce che avevamo disponibili
ma siamo riusciti a posto non ridere
cosa si fa quando rivedrà il video non
devi vivere deve ridere con telecomando
nell'occhio fa malissimo da ragazzi
[Musica]